204 this morning is the deadline for
nevada college students to get
vaccinated against coronavirus for the
spring semester well many have already
taken that stuff but others are refusing
and they do plan to rally at unlv later
today that's where we find hector mejia
joining us now with the details this
morning
hey there this rally is called end the
mandates it's expected to draw dozens of
people and it starts at nine this
morning and runs through noon and
they're protesting the vaccine
requirement put in place by the nevada
system of higher education which covers
eight campuses including unlv where
we're live this morning registration
opens today for the spring semester
students cannot enroll without showing
proof of vaccination or have an approved
medical or religious exemption the
university says registration start dates
vary so not everyone will be signing up
today and students are encouraged to
upload records or submit an exemption
request as soon as possible meanwhile
the deadline for employees to get fully
vaccinated is almost here it's december
1st according to enchi as of last week
82 percent of all unlv staff members are
vaccinated and going back to the rally
it's being organized on facebook by a
group named las vegas freedom of choice
and again it starts in a few hours from
now at 9 a.m reporting live hector mejia
live local now